one of the funny things that i find is a
lot of these women now believe that men
are attracted to their degrees and their
careers and their jobs and it's so not
true the guys that they're attracted to
the high value guys the guys making bank
putting a dent in the universe they're
captivating they're interesting they
have a fantastic life they got a great
network of friends those guys want
nothing to do with a disagreeable woman
they don't want to be led by a woman
they don't want to come home and be told
what to do they want you plugged into
comforting lies that's why i wrote the
unplugged alpha to unplug you guys
there's a reason why our ancestors held
to certain roles for centuries a man
leading the relationship does not mean
the woman is a doormat it just means the
man is taking responsibility a leader
needs people to follow him after all
tribes only have one chief for a reason
none of this partnership if a woman ever
refers to you as your partner that's not
a good sign that's disgusting